all right we continue with all the news
breaking this Friday night now earlier
this week when asked about his
involvement with Hunter Shady dealings
Joe once again he snapped at our friend
and our colleague Fox News White House
correspondent Peter Ducey take a look
there's this testimony now where one of
your sons former business associates is
claiming that you were on speakerphone a
lot with them talking business is that
what never talked business in England
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true
all right here with reaction the co-host
of the hit show The Five our friend and
great legal mind Judge Jeanine Pirro is
with us judge great to have you you know
I I keep calling this the anatomy or the
evolution of a lie I never spoke to
Hunter my brother or anybody about our
foreign business dealings three weeks
ago
um Devin Archer testifying and new
information coming out as we've been
saying from the very beginning
um the president never was in business
with his son or his brother or other
people
um yeah and did he he finally did have
contact with all these people but they
never talked business at all and the big
one is oh James Comer didn't show any
direct payment to Joe so it's all okay
Joe's fine uh you got to give him a for
just flat out lying and creativity but
not one of those things is the same
thing they're all different lies they
are different lies and you have to give
them credit and I agree with you for
carrying on a lie and basically a
cover-up uh for the last what two years
two and a half years Joe Biden has been
in government for almost a half a
century his wife is a school teacher
they have multi-million dollar beach
houses they have all kinds of property
all kinds of money he's worth eight
million dollars and what we're finding
out now is that they've got a justice
department that is in a position to
offer a sweetheart a deal to Hunter
Biden and now all of a sudden because
the American people aren't buying it and
because the American people know it's
not on the level all of a sudden mayor
Garland Garland wants to appoint a
special counsel because he said David
Weiss now said he needs a special
counsel that is a flat out lie Sean and
I'll tell you why he doesn't need a
special counsel because David Weiss
concluded his invest investigation he's
offered a plea deal to Hunter Biden they
gave him immunity that is legal
protection against any prosecution in
perpetuity so if you give someone legal
immunity for the rest of their lives
against any prosecution why do now you
all of a sudden you need a special
counsel to investigate and this guy
David Weiss is the same guy who offered
a plea deal that didn't pass legal
muster with a federal judge who believed
that this thing was beyond the judging
she had seen it shouldn't be David Weiss
you're right he's the one he went
against his own office that recommended
felony charges he gave the sweetheart
deal he's the one guy that was
identified by the whistleblowers as
saying one thing to them and a very
different thing in public and by the way
if the whistleblowers who took
contemporaneous notes are correct that
would mean that not only that he lie
before Congress I believe but also that
Merrick Garland lied before Congress so
Garland picks the one guy the
appointment of him is a sham to me what
do you make of the appointment of him in
particular they should have picked
somebody that's independent they should
have picked someone number one outside
of the government number two he's
already indicated he's compromised he's
the one who put together a plea deal
Sean that gave Hunter immunity for the
rest of his life but then said the
investigation was continuing why so that
Congress the Republican house cannot
investigate so he puts together a plea
deal of federal judge will not allow to
go and then he comes back and he says
after he said he had all the power he
needed to Jim Jordan but said in a
meeting with the FBI and the IRS in
October of 2022 I'm not the one making
the decisions and the U.S attorney in
D.C is not giving me permission to
prosecute in D.C all you need to do is
bring in the seven people who are at the
meeting that where he said he didn't
have the power and he doesn't have the
ability to go forward and we make David
Weiss to be a liar great analysis judge
good to see you we appreciate you being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not not get it anywhere else